no like when i came in  a lot of the fans were like who the [ __ ]  is this guy he's going to ruin  everything and uh  that kind of like really made me like  quite happy to hear that i was like yeah  who am i i am going to ruin everything  and then i was like oh then maybe that's  the way to do it maybe i should try and  like really you know like ruin  everyone's expectations of what these  thor films are because you know those  first two thor films were great but now  i can't do with films like that you know  that's they're sort of a bit too  dramatic for me and i can only sort of  do what's you know in my wheelhouse or  the things i'm interested in so i've  really concentrated on like  going like  i will do my best to make  the fans proud and to make them like  understand that there are different ways  of telling a thor story